I'm not that afraid of AI because I'm
more afraid of natural stupidity than
artificial intelligence but I also from
a point of view of a mathematician there
are things I think are currently still
so far beyond I think that machines
would be much better at doing things
like having an immediate knowledge of
all the literature if only we humans
have told them what the literature is so
first of all we have to find a way to
explain to AI what is in the literature
so that's a huge Monumental undertaking
in the first place but then it's about
making connections where you have some
kind of IDE a how do we come up with an
idea and this taxes me a lot because I
often need to come up with an idea and
so I don't know if we understand that
enough to teach AI how to do it those
are the really deep human things that I
think are the furthest down the line
from what AI could do